all right people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message it's
january 26 2022 as always we are
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
tap the notification bell subscribe etc
etc
and
i can't lie to you good people in the
real world it's actually january 25th
right now but on wednesday january 26th
i have a bunch of meetings at rumble's
new headquarters here in the free state
of florida so this is a pre-taped q a i
couldn't lie i
i know i could have i could have
the magic of the internet pre-tapes
things like that it looks like a live
stream
but the truth is today is yesterday and
tomorrow
is something something
um
next week we'll get back to our normal q
a's on thursday situation obviously just
a lot going on here with studio move
and building out things and getting my
furniture in the house and a whole bunch
of other things we will get back to the
regular schedule uh before we get to the
q a we found a great clip you know i've
been trying to do a little bit more of
this these old clips old video clips
that you can find on youtube and other
such places we've had a great clip it's
actually about a nine minute chunk
from a congressional hearing a senate
hearing between joe biden then senator
joe biden and that guy who you know i
dig economist thomas soule
talking about voting rights and racism
and a bunch more we're just going to
show you a 30-second clip up top and
discuss it for a little bit and then
we'll dive right into the q a but before
i do that did you guys know that
restaurant quality steaks can't be
bought at the store that's why you need
moicbox.com moist delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild-caught alaskan
salmon direct to your door helping
family farms become financially
independent outside of big agriculture
their animals are raised outdoors their
fish swim wild in the ocean and moink
meat is free of antibiotics hormones
sugar and all the other junk you find in
prepackaged meat in the meat aisle sign
up at moinkbox.com
reuben get a year of filet mignon
absolutely free and then pick what meats
you want delivered with your first box
change what you get each month and
cancel any time you guys know how much i
love steaks so we could not be more
excited to receive our first package and
are eagerly anticipating grilling up a
delicious new steak dinner in our home i
just got to get my smoker here it's on
the way from l.a moyk was founded by an
eighth generation farmer who was
featured on shark tank host kevin
o'leary said it's the best bacon he's
ever tasted they guarantee you'll say
oink oink i'm just so happy i got moikt
is this going to be demonetized
join the moynk movement today go to
moinkbox.com
reuben right now and our listeners to
this show will get a free filet mignon
for a year that's one year of the best
filet mignon you'll ever taste but for a
limited time spelled m o i n k box dot
com slash reuben that's pointbox.com
reuben and now back to me all right so
i've been trying to do a little bit more
of this type of thing so that we don't
just get lost in the minutia of the day
and oh my god they said this then and
then that person said that and cable
news and everyone's bananas
some time-tested videos that have been
out there for a while that i think can
help us frame how we got to the sort of
crazy place that we're in right now this
is a senate hearing from about 30 years
ago this is joe biden questioning
economist thomas soule on race
and voting rights how about literacy
tests
was that you did i see no problem no
reason why people shouldn't be literate
in order to vote the question is if you
have a black who comes in with his
degree from harvard and the man behind
the desk says no you're not literate you
can't vote
then this you see this is what bothers
me people are talking about how judges
should be sensitive to this particular
group or that particular group and if
that means anything if it means he's
applying the law differently that's
precisely how blacks were held down for
generations in the southwest so i
actually saying the law differently
okay so that's just a small 30-second
bite of about a nine-minute full
exchange between biden and seoul but the
reason i wanted to play today was i
thought it's just such a perfect
explanation in some ways of how we got
here with identity politics how we got
here with this neo-racism that is
basically just everywhere at this point
right what seoul is saying is you know
uh we should not care about someone's
skin color so if you have a literacy
test and you make a harvard educated
lawyer take that literacy test and the
white guy could just walk in and do his
thing
then that would be a problem but you
want the law applied equally to everyone
individual rights equality not equity
it's just so perfect and you can even
see right there and you see a more of it
in the fuller clip where joe biden he
wants to somehow frame it that
everything is racist this is
unfortunately what
i now see the liberals have been doing
for a long long time here you have a
conservative really a libertarian
economist just saying hey equality for
everybody no special tests for anyone to
be able to vote if you're legally here
you get to vote pretty great
and then unfortunately you've got the
supposed good democrat liberal who was
at robert byrd's funeral former what was
he the grand master of the kkk uh yeah
something like that uh you know
basically the implication being oh you
somehow want it to be harder for black
people to vote because you must be a
self-hating black man
i think you got the point all right
let's get to the q and a there's a whole
bunch of questions today uh billy says i
feel guilty that i got a pass on the
osha mandate but health care workers got
the shaft what more can we do this is a
great question so you may remember about
a week ago the supreme court struck down
one of the two mandates so the one that
they struck down was that companies over
a hundred employees
were going to have to force their
employees to be vaccinated that lawsuit
as you know was led by the daily wire
and army dylan and great work
i'll give you some applause jeremy
boring and ben shapiro and the rest of
the guys over at the daily wire so that
one was struck down but at the same time
and i believe it was brett kavanaugh
believe it or not it was his deciding
vote on this they left in the mandate if
you work in the health care field
now i mentioned this last week when when
this all went down i mean what seems odd
to me about this is that if something is
constitutionally your right if you have
a right to medical privacy if you have a
right to free speech etc etc then it's a
right regardless of what field you work
in now i have not read kavanaugh's
entire
piece on this so i can't give you the
full insight into what his thinking was
however that being said obviously you
guys know my opinion on this they should
have struck everything down and then
leave it up to people to make the right
choices you don't want the government
forcing the health care
companies to do certain things now if a
hospital had a policy
that wasn't being forced by the
government would i love it would i love
it that the hospital would say hey to
work here not only if you're a doctor or
a nurse but a janitor janitor or an
administrator you have to be injected
with something i would not love that
policy but i think this is what freedom
is all about and choice is all about and
other hospitals could say hey we don't
do that and then people can get other
jobs and as i always say that's just the
messiness of freedom it's not it's not a
perfect system because
we're not perfect we can't create a
perfect system but you have chance to
move around and say hey i don't want to
work here i don't like these policies
i'm going to go there this company could
come in and say hey we have better
policies et cetera et cetera
so i could leave some of that to the to
the businesses themselves to the
hospitals etc um but the idea that the
government is coming in and saying to
these health care companies hey this is
what you got to do
it doesn't seem quite right your
question is what more can we do
i guess just keep talking about it keep
talking about it and actually
when you go to the doctor
um you know say to your doctor hey can i
take the mask off in
you know me personally even though this
isn't about you wearing the mask at the
hospital or at the doctor's office it's
like hey can i take the mask off when
i'm sitting in the um waiting room let's
say like the more we do to show people
hey we want to go back to real life i
think that's that's like the bottom way
up of looking at things like when you
just go out and live your life and then
eventually the receptionist might be
like hey you know i don't really want to
wear the mask either then they might
talk to the doctor and the doctor may be
like hey you know i maybe i should talk
to my three partners and it turns out
three of the four of us don't want to
wear masks like i think there's a way to
do this that isn't just like ah the
machine has to save all of us wayne says
what's your position on the ukraine
fiasco and how do you think biden is
handling it war in ukraine when will it
start so we'll obviously cover this more
you know i haven't touched it that much
because it just feels
messy and
gross and dishonest the media coverage
of it long story short i mean i think
you guys get the the basic bones here
putin is about to invade ukraine this
has been going on for a long long time
uh basically trying to sort of reinstate
the old ussr
the question is
should we do anything and what will we
do now there's this idea of nato right
this idea that this giant you know
international fighting force is going to
save anyone and you know if one nato
country is attacked then we all will do
something the simple truth is that's
just nonsense it's just a piece of paper
it doesn't mean anything it's either the
u.s does things or nobody does things
that's just the reality of the world in
some ways that's nice because it gives
the us a real flexibility in the world
in terms of trying to get our ideas out
there however our ideas right now ain't
that great the guy in charge obviously
uh isn't the sharpest knife in the
drawer etc etc
so look i don't want us to go to any
wars i don't want troops on the ground
defending ukraine against russia putin's
obviously a bit of a loose cannon i mean
you know do we have a red line does
biden really
think that he can scare putin into doing
something it seems like they're just
going to take ukraine and i don't know
that we're supposed to do anything even
if it's not
the right thing even if it's not the
right thing i just don't know i think
america is so screwy right now we have
so many internal problems that this is
the catch 22 when you're the the last
remaining superpower if we don't do it
nobody will as i said nato as an
organization does not do it's like is
france going to go in there and do it no
is the uk going to go in there and do it
no obviously right so it's like if we do
something then maybe
evil doesn't spread on the other hand
just doing more of the stuff that never
works doesn't work either and they kind
of end up hating us either way so maybe
we have to they clean our own room first
perhaps
maggie says hey dave any news on how us
and locals can join in through monetary
investment in this new rumble adventure
i'm so impressed that so many big names
have jumped on the locals bandwagon and
i look forward to learning how a bundle
subscription to having a bundle
subscription so i can be part of more
creators communities so first off we are
working on the bundle thing you guys
have been asking for it a long time this
is so that if you subscribe to me and
you subscribe to scott adams and greg
gutfeld and dan bongino and whoever it
is that you're not just endlessly paying
more and more and more we want to figure
out a way to discount that we're trying
to do some sort of ranked thing based on
who you interact with the most it's it's
very complex we have to get all the
creators to sign on to do something like
that so we're working on it though we're
working on as as i said although this
appears to be live i pre-taped this
yesterday and i'm actually at rumble
right now and i'm having meetings and i
might be having a meeting about this at
this very moment uh your larger question
about investment you know look i cannot
give you and i would not pretend to be
any sort of financial expert and i truly
can't give you any uh advice in terms of
investing or that sort of thing
however
the cfvi stock
which is cantor fitzgerald
it's the spac that rumble went public
with
it's out there it's out there that's
really that's really all i can say i
believe in this company which is why
we did this merger between local locals
and rumble
but i can't really say any more than
that but you should do your due
diligence and your own research and
maybe we can just build this parallel
economy and save the world maybe i don't
know
mark says satorical question are jackets
still required for podcasters
journalists politics people who are
speaking online or on tv especially if
they live in florida ahem yes i'm still
wearing the jacket in studio we
discussed i think we're going to start
doing some some evening shows as well so
you know the daytime show
our 11 a.m show will be sort of the news
show that you guys always know where i'm
just bringing you the news and we're
just talking it out and all that uh but
you may remember last week we did that
test show here where i was just wearing
a regular shirt and i had a paloma and
it was a little more casual i had my
nice evening in florida background
behind me
so we will mix it up but i do think i
think if you're going to communicate
some of these ideas
uh in a mature way which is what i try
to do and as i always say you guys i'm
not trying to bludgeon you with all this
stuff but if i'm trying to communicate
with you in an in a
in a decent way in a professional way
then i should look the part like yes i
could be wearing a t-shirt right now
like obviously i could and that's not to
knock any of the guys that do something
roughly like this that that where that
stuff i mean rogan does his show mostly
in a t-shirt it's a different vibe than
what we're doing here i like to think
that i'm sort of like right on the cusp
sort of between like
the the online world and something that
is mainstream i would never want to be
mainstream i would never take a job at a
cable news organization i really i
assure you that i am my own boss i run
these companies i i love what i'm doing
here and owning all of it and all that
stuff
but i think there's a way to you know it
it is that stand up straight with your
shoulders back you know wear clothes
that fit you know do your hair right
look good like and then and then i can
communicate some of those things as
opposed to you know just coming here and
greasy and sweaty and old ratty t-shirt
so yes i am wearing a jacket got it at
nordstrom rack this one if i'm not
mistaken
debra says did you see that the fda is
pulling the use of monoclonal antibodies
please comment on this are they trying
to kill people so if you didn't see this
it's just in the last couple days the
fda so at the federal level they're
basically stopping monoclonal treatment
now
i told you guys when we got to florida
right before christmas
i got covered david got covered bunch of
my employees got covered i was able to
get monoclonal treatment here within an
hour basically i hadn't even tested
positive yet for cobit david had tested
positive really wasn't feeling well i
was a little achy or whatever and we got
monoclonal treatment i then had
ivermectin and i was basically okay in a
couple days it did take david a little
bit longer but the point is that there
were these uh
basically there were these units set up
throughout the state where you could go
and get monoclonal treatments and and if
you couldn't even get into one of those
there were ways to do it privately et
cetera et cetera
they've decided to stop this the federal
government does not like you having the
ability to find alternative treatments
so the question is why is it that they
want everyone to get vaccinated and
double vaccinated and triple vaccinated
and boosted and then still wear a mask
and now wear an n95 mask and still not
go out if you live in dc or la or new
york city etc etc so are they trying to
kill people i
at this point i don't know what the hell
these people are trying to do i really
don't know but i think that the
pharmaceutical companies clearly clearly
these people who have lied all along if
you get the vaccine you will not get
covered nor transmit it live repeated by
the president repeated by fauci et
cetera et cetera it's like why are these
people they occasionally they get hauled
in front of congress that doesn't do
anything but but these people should
should be shamed
relentlessly shamed you have a right to
make health care decisions for yourself
and if you can get monoclonal treatments
and there is plenty of evidence that
they work
you know that at least they were working
before omicron it's sort of up in the
air how effective they were with uh with
omicron but they were certainly
effective with delta and even if they're
not really it's like they're just
jabbing us with with stuff to be
injected with that we don't seem to
really know much about so why are they
stopping this i mean that really is the
question so are they trying to kill
people i don't know if they're trying to
kill people but i think they just are
trying to shift everybody to become
zombies who will get a monthly
subscription to their vaccine
brad says with the population
re-concentrating itself based on
political philosophy are we nearing a
moment where we have fully opted out
from interactions with those we are out
of alignment with to what end i mean you
know i talk about this one a lot it's
like
this is this is dangerous in some ways
and it's scary in some ways this idea
that america will sort of
split into potentially two very
ideologically different countries like
there's something very scary about that
it doesn't seem like the united states
of america certainly not the word united
on the other hand maybe this is right
and maybe this is why
america is actually standing up better
to some of this authoritarian nonsense
than say a place like australia or
certainly a place like canada other
countries that we really thought were
free western countries that don't have
these great options you know there's
there's different provinces in australia
but they don't have 50 states that can
make decisions for themselves that it is
laid out in our founding documents that
the states are supposed to do most of
the stuff and what is not specifically
given to the federal government as
authority is left back to the states
this has been the great chance of
america i mean imagine if we did not
have states rights right now and the
biden administration and the fda and the
nih and fauci and all of these people
had just been putting these blanket
draconian laws and edicts they're not
even laws actually these edicts uh over
all of us we'd be in really bad shape i
i would be uh probably not smiling here
in florida right because it wouldn't
matter whether i was here or not but
instead we have states right so a guy
like ron desantis can say hey hey hey
we're not going to do any of this
[ __ ] anymore i don't care what you
say and we're going to give our people
monoclonal treatment and now the federal
government can impede on that getting to
the previous question but they can do
everything they they can within their
power the governors that is to run their
states the way they see fit so thank god
this is happening so i think we need
more and more of that i do think we will
see more and more of a split it's just
how it is i also think we'll see a real
split between the city centers and the
rural centers it's just gonna happen
people
freedom loving people how could you be a
basic freedom loving person who wants to
decide how you want to live make choices
for yourself and say i'm going to live
in new york city that seems like a good
idea i'm going to live in los angeles
i'm going to live in san francisco et
cetera et cetera so the freedom-loving
people will get out of those cities the
cities will be inundated and basically
overwhelmed with people who love the
system and then the system is going to
need more money from people but we know
that the system's not very good at
creating jobs because no people will
want to create businesses in these
places so and so look it's sort of
inspiring and it's depressing at the
exact same time but i think the
inspirational part is that perhaps we
don't have all of the answers right now
for everything but you know for you guys
watching this it does mean that right
now we still have a chance to live in
places that are more in line with our
views that has if there's anything that
i have actually put into practice in the
last month and seen for real like that
is it you have a chance you have a
chance find that place like if you're
not happy where you are find
that place and then and then don't just
survive if you're living in a place that
you're not supposed to live in right now
you're just surviving but go somewhere
else and thrive
that really is it
uh jenny says
it occurred to me at work today that i
have to wear a mask while sitting in the
same area as my co-worker but if we went
out to lunch i could sit maskless
any good houses for sale near you yes
well first off the florida market is
booming there's a lot of houses near me
there's tons of construction i've got a
guy
the guy who built my house in los
angeles i'm trying to get him here to
start building here in miami like
there's just so much opportunity
everywhere everywhere in florida as i
said earlier
i'm technically right now although i'm
live to you i'm actually in uh sarasota
and rumble's new headquarters sarasota's
blowing up that's on the the west side
of florida like the whole place is
blowing up so look around but really to
the to the inconsistency of what the
policies are that's really what you're
asking about it's like they make you sit
inside now you both have to wear a mask
you stand up to go to the bathroom you
have to put on the mask you sit down at
the table you can take the mask off
you're on an airplane you're sipping
water you can take it off
in between bites you have to put like
it's all [ __ ] it's all nonsense and
we just have to stop participating in
the lie just stop participating none of
us want to participate you know i've
noticed actually when you go to airports
there's almost no security around
there's no at least at the airports that
i've been to in the last little while
miami airport fort lauderdale airport
which by the way those are fed federally
controlled things so this has nothing to
do with florida specifically but lax uh
the nashville airport like there's not a
lot of security around when you're just
walking around an airport like watching
you making sure that you're wearing a
mask so sometimes you see people without
masks and i usually take my mask off and
then people kind of look at you and they
nod and they smile or get a thumbs up or
let's go brandon or something like that
and it's like everyone else is just sort
of either not thinking they're just
doing what they're told and they're sort
of clone soldiers doing what they're
ordered to do
or they're sort of all doing it to each
other it's something like that like you
just do it because everyone else is
doing it and then you if you were to
look around and go was anyone forcing us
to do this well i guess there was a sign
somewhere but like there's nobody like
you know gonna come smack you right
they're not they're not dragging us off
to the gulag yet uh cynthia says i
thought i'd heard that bill maher was
going to have you on his show or you
were going to be speaking with him with
him somewhere at least is my memory
broken i don't know that i fully mention
this and i'm not exactly sure what i'm
allowed to say
um but i will say i was booked on real
time a couple times originally for don't
burn this book and then one other time
after that and uh maybe one other time
so the two or three times i've been
booked they it got cancelled for
whatever reason one time was definitely
covered related so i'm not
i'm not blaming anybody is what it is um
there may be something coming perhaps in
the next month or so with me and mr marr
and by the way i would just say to that
for those of you that watched the show
yesterday if you didn't i would really
recommend you watch the first 20 minutes
because i had some [ __ ] to get off my
chest
that none of my criticisms of bill maher
are an attack on him personally
this is a difference of political
opinion of two guys that i think were
old school liberals that have now gone
down that road and then the road forked
and i think we've gone in separate
directions on that but maybe not even as
much as it may publicly appear so i
would love to just talk that out i
really mean that that's it this is not
about taking someone out it's not
destroying somebody it's not about
fighting with somebody it's about what
are if the ideas that we believe in
i mean i wrote a book defending
classical liberalism which is what is is
the very set of ideas he believes in as
far as i can tell um it's like if we
can't have that out then then maybe
these ideas aren't that strong in the
first place uh drew says could you give
us your thoughts on the trump verse
establishment internal war for the gop
that we are seeing yeah
it's interesting because you know i've
spent a lot of time over the last couple
days talking about what's sort of
happening on the left that you know we
know that the left basically has has
been just decimated by the woksters and
the identity politics people the
progressives and really socialists i
mean right really that's what they are
show me a democrat politician who in
effect isn't a socialist whose answer to
everything
their answers to everything are always
more and more government right that's
what they are and then there's this tiny
tiny sliver of people who have no
influence in the party in the base and
the energy of the party this is the the
good liberals types the mar types who
are trying to say oh no no this is not
what we're supposed to be doing we
shouldn't be the neo-racist vocism is
bad but there's no political evidence
that what they're doing is working and
i've been arguing that they should be
voting for conservatives and just be
sort of the liberal wing let's say of
the republican party something like that
but your question is about the
republicans and there clearly is now
well you know i don't want to say it's
clear actually it's not quite clear
there is some level of a split between
sort of the trump base right the people
that are the true maga people who show
up to events who absolutely are going to
vote who are the energy who are the
twitter people
that thing and then the sort of more
traditional republicans and and by the
way this split here they had it out
already five years ago when trump ran
the first time because they were never
trump people there were the more
traditional conservatives but then again
there were people like marco rubio let's
say or rand paul
who did not like trump at the beginning
who ended up supporting him because they
ended up liking
a lot of the policies okay so i think
this is where we can do so much better
than what the left and the good liberals
are doing where there is no way this
thing can work out right if you have the
base saying you're all racist and then
this other group's saying no we
shouldn't be calling everyone racist and
then they call you a race it's like that
thing cannot work itself out which is
why i'm trying to to talk about this
with billboard and barry weiss etc
the other on the other hand the wide
tent of conservatism where there can be
some libertarians who let's say
uh want to legalize weed can you want to
legalize weed and still be a
conservative now a traditional religious
conservative may be uncomfortable with
legalizing any sort of drug but of
course they're usually not pushing for
prohibition right they're okay with
alcohol being out there so we have to
have this conversation and i've never
been around a bunch of libertarians and
or conservatives and gotten into one of
these debates and people been like no
get out of here we're not going to talk
to you you're racist
so there is a willingness to discuss
these things as i often bring up
rudy giuliani is a conservative
obviously a trump supporting
conservative he happens to be pro-choice
no one's saying he's not part of the
conservative movement that doesn't mean
that the conservative movement should be
fighting only for pro uh should be
fighting for pro-choice policies but the
point is there's a wide ten of people
that's the beauty
of individual rights folks that's the
beauty you accept
that there are different people than you
out there and that you don't have
dominion over them it's pretty sweet
it's pretty sweet indeed uh guys part
one of my interview with marco rubio
maybe we even talk about this a little
bit actually we do uh is up right now on
youtube the full thing is up of course
ad free reuben report.locals.com
and i will be back live and i mean live
in studio tomorrow at 11 a.m eastern
have a great day everybody
you